[Musique]
bernard cazeneuve le ministre délégué
aux affaires européennes est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir monsieur le
ministre soir merci d'être avec nous le
climat se tend autour de la ratification
du traité européen la gauche se divise
françois hollande aura besoin des voix
de la droite vous ne ménagez pas votre
peine je crois depuis des semaines jour
après jour chaque heure de la journée
presque pour convaincre de la nécessité
d'adopter ce texte synonyme pour ses
détracteurs à la gauche de la gauche de
camisole de rigueur de souffrance des
peuples ententes ont également dans un
quart d'heure et on verra ce qu un qui
suit l'elysée pour l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire vous
interrogera sur les difficultés
économiques qui entraîne bien sûr celle
du pouvoir exécutif avec ce trou d'air
qui se confirme dans les sondages
troisième partie avec perrine tarneaud
de public sénat et laon l'ignorent mais
vous avez une complicité de 20 ans avec
françois hollande nous en parlerons tout
à l'heure les téléspectateurs peuvent
intervenir durant cette émission par le
biais de l'application tivi tchèque de
notre autre partenaire avec afp orange
le traité budgétaire donc d'abord et sa
règle d'or qui sont examinées ce
mercredi au conseil des ministres
françois hollande n'en voulait pas dans
l'opposition on s'en souvient il accepte
désormais au pouvoir grâce au pacte de
croissance qui a été ajoutée mais mais
monsieur le ministre la majorité
n'échappera pas à la discorde
il est normal que sur les questions de
l'europe il y ait un débat à gauche le
débat sur l'europe c'est consubstantiel
au fonctionnement de notre famille
politique il a toujours existé et je
pense que nous aurions tort d'ailleurs
de vouloir l'éviter il faut l'assumer il
faut le conduire il faut aller au devant
de ceux qui peuvent avoir des opinions
diverses sur ce sujet essayer de
répondre à leurs interrogations
c'est ce que je m'emploie à faire depuis
maintenant plusieurs semaines en étant
la disposition des parlementaires des
responsables d'organisations politiques
avec le souci d'expliquer quelle est la
politique européenne du gouvernement
qu'il est bien au delà de ce traité qui
est un élément
recontextualiser essayer d'apporter tous
les éléments de réponse avec la plus
grande énergie je crois tout les petits
rigoureusement fenêtre devant
l'ascenseur sur tout ce qui viendra
après on attend surtout les opposants
aujourd'hui les présidents des groupes
écologiques par exemple au parlement qui
disent on va voter nous on attend le
front on entend le front gauche jean luc
mélenchon qui dit il faut un référendum
plusieurs éléments de réponse d'abord
qu'est ce que nous avions dit pendant la
campagne présidentielle nous avions dit
nous ne voulons pas inscrire la règle
d'or dans la constitution le conseil
constitutionnel nous a donné raison
alors que le précédent pouvoir rouler à
la sauvette rapidement faire en sorte
qu'on inscrive cette règle dans la
constitution deuxièmement nous avions
dit nous voulons réorienter profondément
l'atlantique de moindres on l'avait dit
nous voulons renégocier la goulée ont
réorienté profondément la politique de
l'union européenne et faire en sorte
qu'à côté des disciplines budgétaires
dont nous avons besoin pour rétablir nos
comptes il y ait vraiment des
initiatives pour la personne avait on
dit aux îles nous avions dit aussi qu'il
fallait remettre de l'ordre dans la
finance et qu'il fallait plus de
solidarité au regard de ses engagements
qu'avons nous obtenu nous avons obtenu
un impact pour la croissance de 140
milliards d'euros 120 milliards d'euros
de mobilisation de fonds européens
public qui appelle 120 milliards d'euros
d'investissements privés par effet de
levier ça permettra de faire de la
croissance durable de la transition
énergétique de financer les grands
investissements dans l'europe a besoin
deuxièmement nous avions dit nous
voulons remettre de l'ordre dans la
finance c'est un combat historique de la
gauche nous avons sur le métier la
supervision bancaire nous voulons aller
au delà avec un dispositif de résolution
des crises bancaires et de garantie des
dépôts et nous avions dit le terrine par
là c'est important nous voulons que les
peuples d'europe ne soient pas
confrontées à l'austérité à perte de vue
et pour cela il nous paraît
indispensable que ce ne soit pas les
états qui financent sur les marchés à
des conditions de taux très contraignant
pour eux la recapitalisation des banques
nous avons le mécanisme européen de
stabilité qui permet de recapitaliser
les banques et qui évitera ainsi que les
états n'aient à le faire en ayant là que
le marché et en répartissant la facture
sur les pubs se veut dire concrètement
quoi ça veut dire que aujourd'hui à
travers la croissance la remise en ordre
de la finance et à travers la solidarité
le ms centrale européenne
pérol a été profondément rythme et passe
le départ négocié au niveau du traité ça
il faut le dire c'était une erreur de le
dire maintenant la campagne jeunes aux
jeunes en longe l'argumentation nous
nous avions un traité dont la règle d'or
devait être inscrit dans la constitution
et qui était considérée par le précédent
pouvoir comme l'alpha et l'oméga de la
politique de l'ue n'ont pas d'autre
horizon possible nous nous avons
aujourd'hui la discipline budgétaire
n'est pas dans la constitution
elle fera l'objet d'une loi votée à la
majorité ou alors il y aura le
rétablissement des comptes publics parce
que c'était un engagement de campagne et
à côté il y à la croissance la remise en
ordre de la finance dès maintenant des
mécanismes de solidarité renforcée pour
faire en sorte que la politique de
l'union européenne soit profondément
réoriente alors que moi qui ai voté non
en 2005 contre le traité alors qu'ils
engageaient l'europe dans une pente
libéral qui empêché l'europe d'avoir les
moyens de réorienter sa politique
aujourd'hui je suis mis un gouvernement
qui procède à une réorientation profonde
de la politique de l'union européenne et
on ne peut pas dès lors que dans
l'adversité face à des gouvernements
conservateurs face aux marchés qu'ils
attaquent les états en encourageant
parfois la spéculation ne pas considérer
qu'il est positive de mettre en oeuvre
ce pourquoi on s'est battus quand vous
aurez accès à leur gestion financière
par exemple doit permettre aussi de
doter le budget du mal au pn de
ressources propres deux arguments tout
ça c'est les parias cantat n'est pas
rien aux arguments sont très rôdée à ce
qu'à genève on vous écoute on vit
longtemps qu'on reçoit un argument 6 mai
alors j'entends les arguments
d'esbrouffe hearthland arguments précisé
qu'ils profèrent jeune personne en
particulier mais je dis que sur un sujet
de ce type là il faut être précis
rigoureux et il ya des choses à l'heure
et louis mails regarder du côté
communiste pierre laurent dit ne pas
ratifier s'est donné une deuxième chance
à sa renégociation
et puis le front de gauche cherche à
mobiliser on le sait avec une
manifestation le 30 septembre est ce
qu'elle vous inquiète jeudi à pierre
laurent qui développe l'idée qu'il
pourrait y avoir une renégociation de ce
traité dans un contexte très différent
de celui qui prévalait en juin puisque
depuis juin nous avons obtenu tout ce
que je viens l'élever l'ayant ratifié
les que des pays ont ratifié et que ce
traité entre en vigueur dès lors que
doux ce pays ont procédé à sa
ratification même s'il n'a pas été
ratifié par l'ensemble des pays de
l'union européenne que quelqu'un a
demandé jeudi à monsieur laurent que
demander ça aujourd'hui c'est à dire
bloquer le fonctionnement des
institutions européennes c'est bloquer
les mécanismes de solidarité mis en
oeuvre en faveur des pays qui souffrent
c'est accélérer le paiement de la
facture du redressement de l'économie
par les peuples s'est ajouté une couche
de crise politique à la crise financière
à la crise monétaire à la crise profonde
que dites-vous alain lemarchand douter
de la crise est là crie pas ça surtout
lorsque l'on a obtenu une première étape
qui en appelle d'autres je suppose que
dans l'europe nous gardions notre force
et notre ralliement et que d'une voix
jean-luc mélenchon c'est un peu l'âme la
même bizarrement que ben stiller mais
qui dit lui c'est notre devoir de
réclamer un référendum vous allez
remarquer qu'une très grande majorité
français sont favorables au référendum
il ya plein de jeux répond une chose
précise jean luc mélenchon 7
de ces dispositions que nous allons
entériné au parlement sont des
dispositions qui font l'objet d'une
procédure législative ordinaire
être adoptés n'ont pas la majorité
qualifiée mais à la majorité des
suffrages exprimés et nous avons évité
que ce soit à sery dans la concision
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'abandon de
souveraineté il ya beaucoup de sujets
sur lesquels aujourd'hui les français
pourraient demander un référendum et qui
relèvent non pas d'une transformation
d'une évolution de la constitution et de
processus législatif ordinaire nous
allons transformer la démocratie
française en un système de césarisme
démocratique nous allons appeler au
référendum sur tous les sujets il ya
bien des sujets sur lesquels monsieur
mélenchon pourrait constater qu'il ya
une demande des français de voir le
scénario ne pourrait pas et qui lui-même
souhaiterait que ces textes ne soient
pas soumis au référendum parce qu'il ya
un moment où la démocratie
représentative doit pouvoir jouer donc
nous ne sommes pas engagés sur
l'organisation d'un référendum il n'y a
pas une modification de la constitution
nous avons dit que nous présenterions ce
texte à la délibération parlementaire si
la plainte de l'union européenne étaient
réorientés nous faisons ce qu'on nous
nous sommes engagés à cette
manifestation mais pas répondu la
manifestation appelée par par le front
de gauche de 35 ans n'est pas une pause
à vous inquiète parce qu'ils savent être
le poids de toutes les frustrations et
des science au delà du traité européen
nous on ne bâtit pas une politique en
exploitant les frustrations les
inquiétudes ont conduit une politique en
ayant du courage en essayant de faire en
sorte que cette politique répondant à
l'intérêt général du pays répondent à
l'intérêt général de l'union européenne
moi je comprends parfaitement
l'inquiétude de ceux qui aujourd'hui
sont victimes de la crise qui
s'inquiètent de l'avoir s'enkyster c'est
précisément parce que je comprends cette
inquiétude là que par respect par
conception de ce que doit être l'action
politique lorsqu'on est face à des défis
aussi important on ne doit pas exploiter
cela en détournant le vote son objet il
est aussi certains parlementaires
socialistes qui ne pourront pas voter ce
traité
chacun est libre de moi je ne suis pas
dans une espèce que le d'ores et déjà
merci à la droite ça car c'est ce qu'il
doit faire en conscience je dis
simplement à voir que le remercie non
mais je voudrais d'abord m'adresser à
ceux dont vous parliez à l'instant c'est
à dire tous ceux qui à gauche
s'interroge et s'apprête à émettre
compellent avant elles soient pas à leur
soutien ils ont franchement il ya
d'accord et je le redis nous sommes dans
une situation de combat nous avons en
face de nous de multiples fronts un
président de la république est engagé
dans la réorientation de l'europe plutôt
que de lui compliquer la tâche en
l'empêchant d'avoir avec lui toutes les
dynamiques qui lui permettrait d'aller
plus loin si vous voulez que le
président de la république réussissent à
mettre en oeuvre ce que vous désirez ne
rendez pas ce que vous désirez
impossible en lui compliquant la tâche
mais peut-être que certains
contestataires au front de gauche n'ont
pas envie qu'ils réussissent
celles ci ont demandé leur vous dites
déjà merci à la droite qui va permettre
à françois hollande regardez moi j'en ai
raté mais moi je trouve que c'est
d'ailleurs aussi un message que vous
m'aidez envoyé à tous à toute la gauche
serait-il légitime et normal après que
un gouvernement à présent la république
avec toutes les forces qui les ont
portés au pouvoir s'engage dans la
réorientation de l'europe qu'on laisse
ce plaisir à la droite qui s'est opposé
à cette orientation qui nous a expliqué
qu'elle était impossible d'arracher une
victoire qu'elle ne mérite pas et dont
nous aurions bien besoin pour pouvoir
aller plus loin dans la réorientation de
l'europe parce que ce qu'il faut
comprendre live affaire c'est que si
nous voulons réussir la réorientation de
loeb au delà ce que nous avons obtenu
nous avons besoin d'avoir de la force
tout le monde regarde la france en
europe ce pays si l'on se rend compte de
ce que nous avons obtenu de haute lutte
et contestée parce qu'ils ont demandé à
nos côtés qui sont censés nous soutenir
alors nous serons plus faibles donc vous
dites mais les élus risque de perte
d'autorité de françois hollande anglais
cela je le risque est là non je le dis
pas ça je dis qu'il ya le dr déjà là je
ne dis pas ça je dis qu'il ya une perte
de force et nécessité pour un
gouvernement qui se bat afin d'obtenir
la réorientation d'une politique et
qu'il obtient pour partie et qui sait
qu'il a devant lui d'autres cadors
d'avoir toute sa majorité avec lui pour
que ces autres étapes soient franchies
dans les meilleures conditions c'est
assez cohérent très bien là on a compris
le petit questions rapides avant de
parler
la situation économique et sociale un
mot d'abord sur la question des roms
vous avez accompagné il ya quelques
jours manuel valls en roumanie est ce
que la question de l'aide au retour et
posé il ya une prime de 100 euros par
adulte qui est donné on connaît ses
effets pervers vous allez le remettre en
cause ou non c'est une décision qui doit
être prise par le gouvernement dans son
ensemble et qui ne dépend pas de la
compétence du maire européenne mais nous
avons entendu avec manuel valls des
critiques concernant cette mesure et son
inefficacité et manuel valls a indiqué à
la presse en roumanie que ce sujet
serait examinée expertise et on lui
fournissait une piste est ce que vous
êtes choqués par les nouvelles
caricatures de mahomet en pages
intérieures de charlie hebdo le
président de la répu le présent de la
république et le premier ministre
premier ministre notamment se sont
exprimés sur ce sujet liberté
d'expression laïcité responsabilités et
mature vocation mais la liberté de la
passe n'est pas une provocation rien à
ajouter vous n'avez rien à perdre et de
la presse laïcité responsabilité hervé
hasquin de l' agence france-presse donc
va nous rejoindre pour évoquer les
difficultés qu'affronte le pouvoir la
crise la chute dans les sondages voyons
d'abord comment la progression de la
courbe du chômage avant de s'inverser
dans un an avant cette chef de l'état
continue à sombrer la situation inquiète
le moral de tous les français mounir
souci
psa doux et bientôt peut-être sanofi les
plans sociaux se suivent et le
gouvernement peine à contenir
l'hémorragie
le président a beau se mettre en
première ligne la crise est plus forte
et il ne pourra pas se battre sur tous
les fronts inversée en une année la
courbe du chômage tout en ramenant le
déficit à 3% du pib deux objectifs
affichés qui vont se heurter à une
situation économique dégradée
malheureusement il ya un choix à faire
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas à la fois
réduire drastiquement les déficits
publics c'est à dire mener des plans
d'austérité de grande ampleur tout en
réduisant le chômage sont globalement si
on mène une politique d'austérité de
cette ampleur on aura au mieux très peu
de croissance au pire une récession
tenus par les obligations européennes de
réduction des déficits françois hollande
choisi le camp de l'austérité avec son
plan d'action et son calendrier détaillé
il cherche à fixer un cap le président
dit entrer dans une phase d'accélération
de ces réformes mais la france at elle
les moyens de suivre voit que les marges
de manoeuvre sont extrêmement réduites
on voit que d'ailleurs le gouvernement
fait ce qu'il peut avec le peu de moyens
qu'il a assez rare que mettre en place
des emplois d'avenir le contrat
génération c'est plutôt des choses qui
sont positives pour marcher le travail
mais on voit bien que c'est plutôt des
mesures qui viennent en urgence des
difficultés qui se traduisent dans les
enquêtes d'opinion après un été hésitant
et la mise en scène d'une entrée
énergique l'exécutif poursuit sa chute
dans les sondages la récente reprise en
main n'a pour l'instant aucun effet il
ya aujourd'hui la volonté de la part des
français d'avoir un exécutif qui d'aller
visiter présent qui donne le sentiment
que le politique en prise sur
l'économique et puis ouvre des
perspectives la promesse de campagne de
réenchanter le rêve français sera
difficile à tenir avec des prévisions de
croissance revues à la baisse c'est bien
la réalité des chiffres qui va fixer le
cap du gouvernement
voilà hervé hasquin de l' agence
france-presse avec nous c'est le
correspondant de l'agencé à l'elysée
pour soir hervé votre question à bernard
cazeneuve et bien la question du jour
c'est cette la tva et la csg le point
affirmait que jean marc ayrault pourrait
s'asseoir sur un engagement très fort du
gouvernement est décidé une hausse
finalement de la tva
ces démentis ce soir par matignon qui
démarre en à la fois l'art au cg et de
la tv alors qu'est ce que vous allez
faire comment redresser les finances de
la france comment lutter contre le
déficit sans augmenter ni l'un ni
l'autre la réponse à cette question est
apporté par françois hollande l'occasion
de ces expressions récentes notamment il
ya de cela une dizaine de jours
interrogé par un de vos confrères une de
vos confrères sur une autre chaîne nous
devons rétablir les comptes publics
c'est un engagement que nous avons pris
nous devons le faire pour des raisons
assez simple la dette caubère notre
souveraineté
détérioration continue de nos comptes
publics au cours des dix dernières
années induit des taux d'intérêt sur les
marchés qui rendent impossible la
croissance parce que ceux qui peuvent
faire la croissance qui investissent
sont confrontés à des taux d'intérêt qui
obère les chances d'investir dans des
conditions efficace économiquement et
par conséquent le rétablissement des
comptes publics sur lequel nous sommes
engagés c'est une nécessité en termes de
souveraineté c'est un devoir que nous
avons vis-à-vis des générations futures
et c'est une décision c'est un
engagement d'efficacité de la région
sait comment elle arrive le président de
la république a indiqué qu'elle était la
méthode il a indiqué qu'il y aurait
d'abord des efforts faits de maîtrise
des dépenses publiques dans l'appareil
dès 10h 10 milliards oui 10 milliards de
maîtriser l'ensemble belgique lever 1
milliard 20 milliard de recettes
supplémentaires fisc alors oui l'eau
mais je vous rappelle que la trajectoire
de finances publiques présenté par le
presse précédent gouvernement devant les
institutions de bruxelles puisque depuis
le six pack nous sommes obligés
désormais de présenter une trajectoire
de finances publiques savez-vous quels
étaient les engagements du précédent
gouvernement ce qu'on n'en parle jamais
il serait intéressant de comparer ce que
nous faisons par rapport à ce que se
proposait de faire les autres parce que
c'est à ça qu'on mesure d'apporter d'une
réorientation politique et d'une
alternance connaissez vous ces chiffres
rezidor je vous les donne ces chiffres
c'était 11 milliards de diminution des
dépenses de l'état
c'était 15 milliards de prélèvement
fiscal auquel s'ajoutait 13 milliards de
prélèvements à travers la tva sociale
c'est à dire 28 milliards de
prélèvements et 11 milliards d'économies
avaient monsieur ascain une prévision de
croissance qui était de 1,4 pour cent
nous nous sommes à une période prévision
de croissance beaucoup plus réaliste de
0,8 et nous avons la volonté de faire en
sorte que les économies budgétaires que
nous devons afficher parce que nous ne
pouvons pas rétablir les comptes si nous
ne faisons pas un effort de maîtrise de
nos dépenses 10 milliards et puis il ya
effectivement des prélèvements mais
alors ces prélèvements sont des
prélèvements qui se font dans la volonté
de faire en sorte que les plus riches
des contributeurs français soit appelée
à contribution pendant la période de
redressement de manière à faire en sorte
que ce ne soient pas les plus modestes
les plus faibles des français qu'ils
soient appelés à faire l'effort de
redressement mais c'est à dire que c'est
la politique fiscale inverse de celle
qui a été menée au cours des cinq
dernière mais alors vous peinez à à
convaincre les français
le patronat est inquiète les retraités
sont inquiets le le prix du gaz qui
devait augmenter selon le rythme
d'inflation au plus bas finalement
augmenté bien plus vite est ce que la
crise vous a pris de court est ce que
vous êtes surpris vous saviez à quoi
vous attendre pourtant les français sont
inquiets comment ne le serait-il pas
voilà un gouvernement qui est en
situation d'exercer entretenu
mais je réponds à la question elle comme
on ne le serait-il pas et je répondrai
également à votre interpellation de
l'est de l'instant voilà un pays qui a
été gouverné pendant dix ans par la même
sensibilité politique 600 milliards de
dettes supplémentaires au cours des cinq
années qui viennent de s'écouler une
augmentation record du déficit une
dégradation de notre compétitivité dont
témoigne l'aggravation du déficit du
commerce extérieur 75 milliards d'euros
un chômage qui a augmenté de 1 million
de personnes au cours du dernier
quinquennat et nous trouvons la france
dans cette situation d'inquiétude avec
une europe qui peine à trouver le chemin
d'une réponse rapide dans l'urgence aux
défis que chaque jour lui envoie la
crise et nous nous retrouvons dans une
situation nous prenons le pays dans ce
contexte est ce que nous avons
sous-évalué la crise mais j'étais porte
parole de françois hollande pendant la
campagne présidentielle
je les accompagne et dans beaucoup de
déplacements en province et beaucoup de
déplacements où il allait aux rencontres
à la rencontre des français qui étaient
à quai jamais nous n'avons ni la crise
je me souviens du discours du bourget ou
françois hollande prévenez de
l'importance de l'effort qu'ils seraient
à faire en même temps ce qui ne marche
pas et en même temps les additions que
tout cela devrait se faire dans la
justice mais qui ne marche pas il y
apprit sondages sont si mauvais les
sondages sont mauvais parce qu'il ya une
période de crise qui inquiète les
français et lorsque l'on est en
situation de responsabilité politique
dans une période de crise aussi profonde
et qu'on doit prendre des décisions
aussi difficiles que celles que nous
prenons ça ne peut pas conduire avant
que le redressement est fait son oeuvre
à une irrépressible popularité il disait
toujours le coz grandes avenues
télévision pour essayer justement de
renverser l'opinion pour dire voilà nous
sommes à la tâche le gouvernement indien
mais le président de la république elle
n'est jamais venue à la télévision pour
dire je vais renverser l'opinion c'est
vous qui interprété des raisons pour
lesquelles que l'objectif c'est que j'ai
retrouvé la confiance dans le progrès la
frapper dans la déclaration du président
de la république c'est quelque chose qui
évoquait en moi ce que j'entendais chez
pierre mendès france lorsque la france
était confrontée à une crise d'une autre
nature et que le pouvoir devait y faire
face en sachant qu'ils affronteraient
bien les difficultés le président de la
république a dit seulement une situation
difficile j'ai indiqué que j'engagerai
une politique de redressement dans la
justice je le fais et je le fais en
disant comment je le fais à partir de
quel calendrier et je vous indique que
je vous rendrai compte étape par étape
des décisions que je prends des sujets
que je viens sur le métier pour faire en
sorte que la crise soit surmontée le
président de la république il est allé
devant les français n'ont pas pour les
séduire non pas pour redresser je ne
sais quel courbe des sondages pourtant
d'étaler devant les français pour leur
dire j'ai pris des engagements je suis
en situation de responsabilité dans une
période de crise extrêmement grave
j'entends tenir mes engagements
mon calendrier et vous rendre quand ça
suffit est-ce que ça suffit pour
retrouver les français pour retrouver ce
contact avec les français y ait une
sorte de désamour qui s'exprime dans les
est ce que ça vous un sondage est ce que
ça vous inquiète possède ces panneaux
vite c'est normal la situation de crise
est ce que ça vous ne dites pas que une
autre situation
imaginez qu est ce que ça vous êtes dans
la crise alors que nous prenons des
décisions difficiles nous puissions
malgré tout cela et contrairement à ce
qui se produit dans l'ensemble des
autres pays où des gouvernements sont à
la peine nous soyons confrontés à des
courbes de popularité absolument inouïe
bon ce serait étonnant nous pourrions
nous interroger sur les raisons pour
lesquelles nous bénéficions d'une
situation tout aussi inédit
quotidiennement et des révélations du
pouvoir exécuter ce qui compte
aujourd'hui c'est que face à cette crise
dont les français ont conscience nous
prenions des décisions qui témoigne de
la volonté que nous avons d'assurer le
redressement et surtout et j'insiste sur
ce point de faire en sorte que le chemin
du redressement ne s'éloigne jamais d'un
objectif la justice et voilà à leurs
engagements mais alors vous dites la
justice mais par exemple françois fillon
lui vous reprochent de n'avoir engagé
aucune réforme de structure quelles sont
les réformes de structures qui ont été
engagées quelques répondez-vous à
l'ancien premier ministre mais l'ancien
premier ministre se félicitait d'avoir
engagé des réformes de structures sous
le précédent quinquennat qui étaient des
réformes la justice fiscale et sociale
la droite considère que ne peut être
qualifiée de réforme de structure que
des réformes qui entretiennent dans le
pays de l'injustice sociale et fiscale
et d'ailleurs ils ont été jusqu'à
organisé en catimini à la fin de la
législature dans la précipitation la
plus grande qui ressemble à
l'improvisation la plus totale la tva
sociale comme si on pouvait en trois
mois régler des problèmes de
compétitivité contre lui donc est ce
qu'on aura réglé le problème du chômage
en un an nous avons dit que nous
engagerions des réformes de structure
quelles sont ces réformes figure 1 nous
voulons créer les conditions de
dispositifs fiscaux qui encourage
l'investissement qui encourage
l'investissement dans l'appareil
productif qui encourage l'innovation et
le transfert de technologies plutôt que
la spéculation
les placements financiers ou tout autre
opération à laquelle les entreprises
sont tentées de se livrer lorsqu'elle pc
spécule que l'investir c'est la
réforme de l'impôt sur les sociétés dans
lé public c'est l'alignement de la
fiscalité du capital sur la fiscalité du
travail parce qu'il n'y a pas de raison
non plus que ceux qui travaillent soient
davantage fiscalisés que ceux qui
spéculent qui comme disait françois
mitterrand gagnent leur argent en
dormant donc nous sommes dans une
réforme profonde et 10 de la fiscalité
qui se fera par étapes comme l'indiqué
le premier ministre et père de la
république pour faire en sorte que
l'investissement
l'appareil productif soient favorisés
deuxièmement nous avons besoin dans ce
pays d'organiser des de mettre en oeuvre
des politiques de structures qui
permettent de favoriser la compétitivité
de nos entreprises ne peux pas rester
avec un tel déficit du commerce
extérieur et nous ne pourrons pas
redistribuer du pouvoir d'achat demain
si nous n'avons pas une économie
compétitive qui contribuent à
l'enrichissement du pays ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire un des formations pour
les ressources humaines y compris pour
ceux qui sont les plus d insérer parce
qu'il n'y a pas de raison qu'on laisse
quiconque sur le bord du marché du
travail et la ressource humaine dans
l'entreprise lorsqu'elle est bien formée
et qu'on met en place des politiques
pour atteindre cet objectif c'est une
richesse qui fait de la compétitivité et
on sent le président de la restonica
temps des permis je vais pas la
formation est par ailleurs le fait qu'en
vérité le président de la république a
indiqué qu'ils auraient deux réformes de
structure davantage de sécurité dans les
parcours professionnels
en contrepartie de quoi il pourrait y
avoir plus de souplesse et a renvoyé sa
à la discussion entre les partenaires
sociaux avec une volonté de prendre une
décision à la fin d'année et par
ailleurs il a indiqué que la question du
coût du travail et de la protection
sociale serait mis sur le métier comme
un élément qu'il faut traiter entre les
partenaires sociaux pour décider et le
président de la république a aussi
indiqué qu'à la fin de l'année au terme
de la discussion entre les acteurs
sociaux nous prendrions nos
responsabilités ça nous l'allons lourds
ont fait en six mois alors une chose
qu'il est que tout le monde observe avec
beaucoup d'attention c'est la cohésion
de ce gouvernement
elle a été un peu mise à mal ces
derniers temps et encore aujourd'hui ces
derniers jours sur le vote des étrangers
la question a ressurgi il ya des
ministres qui disait c'est pas une
urgence à manuel valls c'est pas une
préoccupation majeure des français
d'autres qui disent il faut le faire
tout de suite alors d'abord il faut le
faire quand et puis bon c'est 300 cc un
nouveau cafouillage le gouvernement
peine à trouver ses marques jean marc
ayrault un manque d'autorité moi si vous
voulez la meilleure manière de ne pas
rajouter
une strate
de débat ou de polémique où je peux vous
appeler de la confusion
sur des sujets aussi dédicacé et qui
honore non ça veut dire tout simplement
que quand on est ministre dans un
gouvernement on s'exprime sur les sujets
qui relèvent de sa compétence et quand
on ne s'exprime pas sur les sujets qui
relèvent de sa compétence
ce qui n'est absolument pas interdit
quand ce sujet n'a pas été arbitré on le
fait autour de la table du conseil des
ministres
avant que la décision soit prise pour
concourir à la prise de la bonne
décision et on le fait publiquement
quand la décision est prise et arbitrée
par conséquent je suis à ce qu'un si moi
j'avais m'exprimer sur cette question là
je le ferais autour de la table du
conseil des ministres pour favoriser un
arbitrage qui ira dans le sens de ce que
je souhaite une fois que la décision
aura été prise je l'assumerai jeu la
commenterai mais on ne peut pas dans une
période aussi difficile être
gouvernement en y allant chacun de son
côté par conséquent je ne le ferai pas
moi même devant vous non mais parce que
vous avez bien entendu
vous avez bien de tous et surtout d'un
tempérament une faune certaines pas
cette fois de l'état j'estime que quand
on est ministre dans un gouvernement on
participe à la délibération collective
autour de la table du conseil des
ministres
une fois que la délibération collective
a eu lieu il ya deux solutions on est
content on assume on reste on n'est pas
content éventuellement on peut partir
c'est ce qu'ont fait d'autres comme jean
paul finalement rêver
mais dans tout gouvernement il y à des
ajustements il ya des débats j'estime
que ma conception de la politique ma
conception du rôle de ministre mon
éthique dans l'exercice de la
responsabilité gouvernementale me
conduit à ne pas me livrer devant vous à
ce jeu que je trouve inutile d'en
trouver un
on n'a pas besoin de vous rappeler les
évidences effectivement mai
françois hollande avait dû le faire
effectivement sur tf1 il n'a pas été
entendu puisqu'il avait dit c'est la fin
des couacs et y en a encore eu
effectivement avec ces divergences au
sein du gouvernement publiquement
exprimé dernière question est une
question à une question très européenne
qui vous concerne au premier chef cette
affaire de fusion eads b à e c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour l'europe et cialis
de la défense
mais la question c'est c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour l'europe ça pourrait être
une bonne nouvelle crée un mastodonte
face à boeing avec le poids nécessaire
ça pourrait être une bonne nouvelle pour
l'europe et pourtant on sent que paris
et même berlin sont réticents qu'est ce
qui gêne qu'est ce qui vous gêne
le questionnement sur ce sujet c'est un
questionnement techniques
essentiellement parce que les deux
groupes sont deux groupes qui ont des
spécialités en matière
d'activités industrielles très
différentes il y a un groupe qui est
très centrée sur la défense mais a eu un
groupe qui s'est beaucoup orientée vers
les activités civiles
eads il ya pour chacun de ces deux
groupes européens des relations de
partenariat qui existe sur des sujets
stratégiques avec des groupes qui ne
sont pas européens et par conséquent
énormément d'obstacles techniques à
lever qu'ici on n'aimait pas
immédiatement en ligne de mire risque de
bloquer l'opération de roches que je
n'ai pas
respectivement ciment n'engageront il
fait passes ont fait pas d'effusion pour
garder une base industrielle avec pour
premier objectif de réduire le niveau
des emplois et des emprises industriels
sur le territoire européen vous inquiète
ce n'est pas le sujet en l'occurrence
qui me préoccupe sur cette affaire là ce
qui me préoccupe c'est la dimension
technique qui justifierait presque d'une
émission particulier le tir est selon
moi je veux bien rester un peu rageant
temps l'allemagne sur le sujet qui peut
justifier un moment donné qu'on prenne
des précautions pour assurer le mariage
entre un groupe très spécialisés dans
les affaires de défense est un groupe
qui s'est couvert à des activités
civiles valeur mais en revanche le
regroupement nos industries de défense
pour avoir une base industrielle de
défense qui en europe permettent de
faire face à la concurrence
internationale est une nécessité dès
lors qu'on veut avoir une politique
européenne de sécurité et de défense
pertinent faible voilà merci hervé
paternot arrive
monsieur le ministre juste après cette
enquête d'alexandra colline au mieux sur
vous sur votre parcours un proche à la
fois pendant des années des décennies
même de laurent fabius est de françois
hollande mais comment est ce que vous
avez fait
s'il ya un nom sur qui personne n'aurait
parié au ministère des affaires
européennes c'est bien le sien bernard
cazeneuve le moins europhile de tous
celui qui a dit non au référendum de
2005 puis au traité de lisbonne en 2008
nul n'aurait misé non plus sur sa
nomination comme porte parole de la
campagne de françois hollande lui le
fidèle fabusien mais l'homme est aussi
l'ami de 20 ans du président cet avocat
discret et donc un paradoxe un lien
entre deux courants est le trait d'union
pourrait être une belle définition si ça
ne faisait pas quelque chose
d'invertébrés le quinquagénaire confesse
volontiers sa timidité maladive
mais se dit très tenace preuve en est
son acharnement dans la sphère de
l'attentât de karachi rapporteur de la
mission d'information
il avance la thèse des rétrocommissions
malaise à l'assemblée at il oui ou non
monsieur le premier ministre un système
de commissions adossé à ce contrat et si
oui à qui ces commissions ont elles
bénéficié deux ans plus tard étant à
nouveau d'obtenir des réponses sur ce
dossier secret défense esclandre dans
l'hémicycle bernard cazeneuve a été le
rapporteur de la mission d'information
parlementaire sur la sphère de karachi
s'exprimer devant l'assemblée nationale
le règlement
en partisans ump et non président de la
représentation nationale a conçu la
tension aujourd'hui celui qui a pour
devise ne pas hésiter à déplaire si
c'est utile à la tâche délicate séduire
les députés de sa propre majorité
réfractaire au traité européen de
stabilité quelqu'un qui votent par le
mécanisme européen de stabilité puis
ensuite qu'ils défendent et qu'il le
fait avec la même conviction
je j'emploie le terme d'habileté
avec eux serait pour sa part
habileté oui dit jean leonetti pour pas
dire retourné sa veste peut être un non
mais moi je ne rentre pas dans ce type
de considérations qui correspondent
d'ailleurs absolument pas à la manière
dont je fais de la politique et la
manière dont je m'engage en réalité 2005
le ms dont il parle est aujourd'hui pour
moi c'est une cohérence en 2005 nous
voulons une autre europe cette autre
europe nous sommes en train de la faire
au moment du vote sur le mécanisme
européen de stabilité nous sommes
abstenus nous n'avons pas voté contre
pourquoi parce qu'il existait un lien
entre le mécanisme européen de stabilité
dans les textes qui nous était présentée
et le traité qu'on nous présentait comme
l'horizon unique et indispensable de la
politique de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui nous avons donné à l'union
européenne un autre horizon nous
essayons de faire en sorte que nous
puissions avoir de la croissance de la
solidarité des mécanismes de stabilité
renforcée nous essayons de faire en
sorte que l'europe est une politique
industrielle et qu'elle s'engage sur le
chemin du développement durable qu'elles
permettent de faire en sorte que le
mécanisme inter d'interconnexion
européens soient financés à travers un
grand projet donc c'est tout cela que
nous essayons de faire et moi je suis
dans la cohérence qui ne sont pas dans
la cohérence sont ceux qui ont voulu en
2005 une réorientation de la politique
de l'union européenne et qui ne
l'accompagnait pas lorsqu'elle devient
possible ce sont ceux qui voulaient une
europe exclusivement punitive avec des
disciplines budgétaires sans croissance
qui nous expliquait que la croissance
n'était pas possible et qui dès lors
qu'on l'obtient explique qu'elle était
dans les tuyaux c'est là qu'elle
accueille posé sur vos convictions
européennes dans les capitales
européennes quand vous avez été nommé au
vu de votre parcours de votre double non
à la fois en 2005 et au traité de
lisbonne également également au vu du
parcours de laurent fabius l'a voté je
n'étais pas député oui mais vous étiez
engagé et oui d'accord mais je n'ai pas
voté au moment du traité de lisbonne
n'était pas député je n'ai pas eu à le
faire mais en revanche j'ai voté
effectivement sur le traité
constitutionnel en 2005 non j'ai voté
donc pourquoi mais senti la balle aux
nominations certaine réticence du
capital en glissant j'ai senti bien
entendu les interrogations sur le fait
qu'on nomme au ministère des affaires
européennes un responsable politique
parlementaire qui avait eu des positions
très claires sur un certain nombre
d'actes qu'avaient pu poser l'union et
puis très vite parce que l'europe c'est
une mécanique c'est une mécanique on
prend des positions ou rencontre des
acteurs j'ai eu l'occasion d'expliquer
que le non de 2005 n'était pas à nos
anti européen c'était un nom d'espérance
en une autre europe et j'ai eu
l'occasion d'expliquer autour de la
table dès 27 que ce que nous étions en
train de faire la croissance
la taxe sur les transactions financières
la supervision bancaire c'était
précisément ce pour quoi nous nous
étions refus passé devient finalement
des atouts aujourd'hui s'il part c'est
parce que nous ne voulions pas hier nous
sommes en train de le corriger c'est
quand même extrêmement intéressant quand
on est en politique et qu'on s'est
battus pour quelque chose qu'on n'a pas
réussi à obtenir de pouvoir essayer de
l'obtenir en étant dans l'exercice du
pouvoir le pouvoir ça consiste à un
moment donné à prendre des sujets
difficiles sur lesquels on prend des
risques et d'essayer de faire en sorte
de tendre vers l'objectif auquel on
croit c'est ce que je fais
y'a pas d'habileté là dedans et une
sincérité absolue et ma vie politique
qui est encore courte et qui déjà
beaucoup plus longue qu'elle ne le sera
demain est une vie politique où je me
suis constamment engagé avec sincérité
et passion sur les choses et vous avez
été vous avez aussi à la rencontre de
nos gros de nous grand pardon européen
je pense à jacques delorme chaleur
dollar valait giscard d'estaing ça c'est
les rencontres que vous avez fait aussi
à votre nomination
qu'est ce que vous recherchez comme
conseil auprès de chiens des gens
cherchaient pas de conseils je cherchais
à comprendre cherché à savoir je
cherchais à relier les fils de l'action
qui avait été la leur hier
l'action que nous conduisons aujourd'hui
moi je ne crois pas que healy comme
d'autres ont pu le penser à certaines
occasions des ruptures qui permettent
d'organiser à chaque alternance des
grands soirs je ne conseille peut-être
le plus marquant que vous avez retenu de
ces entretiens allez avec 2 qui
s'ils n'ont mais bon quand même langue
non non
non mais j'ai surtout vécu des moments
émouvants à l'occasion de ses rencontres
avec ce que beaucoup d acteurs qui est
j'ai rencontrés sont des hommes qui ont
une grande expérience quand aujourd'hui
il y en a certains qui
pensent que quand
valéry giscard d'estaing à l'appliquer
la manière dont il conduisait ses
relations avec helmut schmidt lorsqu'à
l'occasion du déjeuner avec jacques
delors qui titre d'une acuité sur les
sujets qu'ils connaissaient tous les
mécanismes européens comme s'il était
encore aux affaires m'expliquer le lien
qui existait entre ce qu'il avait
cherché à construire est ce que nous
essayons de faire aujourd'hui vous
rendez compte de l'enrichissement pour
moi qui arrivait dans cette responsable
et qui était d'ailleurs très admiratif
du combat mené par ces grands acteurs
européens
alors bernard cazenave ya une question
qui nous arrive de notre partenaire
orange sur l'application tvcheck une
question de antoine comment voter les
électeurs réagissent à la tenue d'une
conférence sur l'environnement peut-être
rappeler qu'effectivement vous êtes élue
d'une circonscription qu'on présente
souvent comme la plus atomique de france
parce qu'il y ait à la fois à l'usiné de
la hague et les unes de flamanville 1
écoutez je n'ai pas fait le sondage vous
en faites beaucoup déjà je vais pas en
faire de plus je pense que non mais
beaucoup beaucoup de de ceux qui vivent
dans les régions où l'activité nucléaire
profondément pourvoyeur d'emplois
souhaite bien entendu que le nucléaire
continue à avoir une place dans le panel
l'emblématique français oui moi c'est
une position que j'ai toujours eue je
pense qu'il est important que le
nucléaire garder une place dans le panel
énergétique français parce que il permet
d'avoir un prix de l'énergie un bilan
carbone qui est un atout pour la france
ce qui ne m'empêche pas de considérer ce
qui ne m'empêche pas de considérer que
le président de la république a raison
de vouloir réorienter la politique
énergétique parce que ce qui fera la
force de la france c'est d'avoir un
bouquet énergétique le plus diversifié
possible ce que nous avons fait sur le
nucléaire nous devons être capables de
le faire sur le renouvelable nous devons
être capables de le faire sur l'éco
construction nous devons être capables
de le faire en terme d'économie
d'énergie donc la france sera plus forte
si elle a un bouquet énergétique
diversifiée si les énergies nouvelles
font de l'industrie sur le territoire
national parce que nous avons besoin de
réindustrialiser double langage du
gouvernement c'est l'accusation ce soir
sur notre site publicsenat.fr de noël
mamère à propos du nucléaire mais il y a
un discours du gouvernement qui est
équilibré mais nous n'avons jamais
préconisé la sortie du nucléaire nous
avons préconisé une diminution de la
part du nucléaire dans le panel
énergétique français pour assurer le
développement des énergies renouvelables
des énergies de demain nous avons dit
que nous le ferions en accompagnant les
groupes industriels qui s'engageraient
dans cette voie tout en garantissant le
maintien d'une activité nucléaire dont
nous avons besoin est-ce qu'il faut
limiter l'interdiction du cumul des
mandats aux sénateurs non je pense que
le cumul des mandats s'applique à tout
le monde la personne
pourtant
je n'ai pas énormément je n'ai pas
d'avis maintenant là encore on est dans
un processus il y à une commission qui a
été mise en place par le président de la
république était est confiée donc avant
de par exception de new vegas et je dis
simplement qu'il faut je ne sais pas
même pas d'ailleurs si cette exception
c'est vrai c'est ça gérer
constitutionnel je pense que la question
du cumul des mandats doit être abordée
en recherchant le plus grand consensus
possible entre les formations politiques
en même temps il ya un engagement du
président de la république le président
de la république a dit souhaiter mettre
en oeuvre cet engagement il a confié à
lionel jospin le soin de faire dans la
convention en laissant cette procédure
doit accomplir tranquillement et ne
tentera pas sur des sujets de ce type
inutilement l'aquarelle sur l' affaire
karachi on vous a vu intervenir à deux
reprises dans le sujet la cour d'appel
de paris a validé hier le volet
financier de l'enquêté est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment qu'on va connaître un
jour la vérité dans cette affaire il
faut se battre pour la vérité
moi je continuerai à le faire parce que
les liens que j'ai avec cherbourg et les
familles qui achève auront souffert avec
ce territoire qui m'a beaucoup donné
sont indestructibles et que j'estime
comme un devoir moral de continuer en
bas d'ailleurs est un sujet sur lequel
le président de la république a pris des
engagements et sur lequel nous restons
mobilisés c'est la question de la
protection statutaire pour que les
familles des victimes puissent
bénéficier de cette protection pouvoir
financer leurs frais de justice qui leur
permettront d'accéder à la vérité sur l'
enquête sur nantes par exemple de la
levée du secret défense le président de
la république a pris l'engagement que il
y aurait une et classification de la
totalité des documents demandés par les
juges vous savez que la procédure secret
défense est encadré le juge demande la
commission consultative du secret de la
défense nationale se prononcer les mises
et classifie pour ce qui concerne les
demandes nouvelles formulées par les
juges le président de la république
indiqué qu'il y aurait une
déclassification totale et cet
engagement sera tenu en kanté juge
demandant laurent cumont mais reste 30
secondes on a évoqué votre aux liens
d'amitié à la fois avec laurent fabius
et françois hollande vous êtes le seul
socialiste à avoir fait comme ça la
jonction donc si vous voulez moi je le
refais abus je lui dois tout en
politique c'est avec lui que j'ai appris
les choses et il a été un extraordinaire
mentor et les liens qui sont très
anciens que j'ai avec lui sont des liens
là aussi indestructible françois
hollande je les rencontre au début des
années 90
il y a eu spontanément une relation
amicale de confiance et à mesure que le
temps passe et nous nous sommes vus de
plus en plus c'est cette relation s'est
renforcée voilà je n'ai pas donné
d'explications
mais ils s'aiment beaucoup
ne mérite pas le montrer ballon mais
vous avez tort ils sont dix travaillent
de façon très étroite avec l'autre
laurent fabius joue un rôle extrêmement
important dans ce gouvernement sauvage
est compliquée et les cliques île à
françois hollande et françois hollande a
besoin de lawrence le pouvoir change la
donne ses récents efforts merci à vous
monsieur même merci perrine bonsoir à
tous et la semaine prochaine françois
rebsamen le président du groupe
socialiste au sénat sera notre invité il
ne partage pas du tout votre sentiment
sur le cumul des mandats à bientôt
[Musique]